the guy on Jeopardy lost and what's his
name holds our yeah James house an hour
no James Halton power house impossible
awesome father James Hasselhoff so uh
first of all Richard such a weirdo
Richard Christie who works for us he
cried when the guy lost he's got
problems he's so weird he doesn't know
this man will came to me and he said
Richard's going around scratching his
bald head and he's like making a hole in
it and then it turns out Richard had a
spider crawling on him and thought it
would be interesting to see the spider
crawl on him and then he lost track of
the spider and now he goes I know the
spider is not on my head but I keep
feeling like it is that I keep
scratching my head
first of all a he was crying during
Jeopardy and B he allowed a spider to
crawl on him tell this story last night
a spider was crawling across my shirt
and you just and you were like hey I
just wanted to crawl on me for a while
yeah I didn't bother him I was just kind
of looking at it I was like I'm not
scared of spiders I am I would have
freaked out and then it just crawled it
went inside my shirt and then I couldn't
find it and now you think it's on your
head it's probably in my mind that I'm
like now a little weird why did you just
shower in the get rid of the whole now
that would be to it I will eventually
yeah you're scratching your head again
yeah did you feel the spider on I'm it's
in my mind I imagine but it could be on
me see sure it was a real spider yeah it
was definitely real yeah but my biggest
fight it's probably eating the other
bugs that are on me so that's good yeah
but I mean it's really weird it's like
you're in a horrible and why did you cry
when the guy in jeopardy my god my wife
and I both we were you guys found each
other oh we love James like he's like
the freaking Michael Jordan of Jeopardy
and yeah but he's not because he didn't
get the Jennings is the Michael Jordan
he's the LeBron yeah but but tell Robin
your theory you see everyone's running
around with the theory about this guy
and I just think he lost the guy who
watches bugs crawl across this shirt
there's so many things that rant in my
head because it's like so weird that he
would lose right before he beat Ken
Jennings you would want to put out the
theory that he didn't want to be Ken
Jennings
I might have my you don't remember that
through his mind including a spite
exactly I hear I hear a new theory every
second and I'm like okay that could be
true what is it Gary
this morning in our meeting you said you
wanted to lose because he was tired and
he didn't know I said I had heard people
say that that maybe he was tired and
wanted to go home well Joe may be good
now so you just said that Richard on the
Internet
oh there's oh my god there's so many
three John Hines theory though John has
a theory that jeopardy rigged it so that
they knew that this woman was a really
excellent player yes so they held her
back from playing until right until this
guy was about to beat Ken Jennings why
don't they want him to beat Ken Jennings
what is their attachment to Ken yes John
this is a [ __ ] nutty theory my
thought is that when it got to the Ken
Jennings money thing they would put him
up against the best contestant they had
and think okay if he beats her then he
deserves it yeah when you look at her 27
year old librarian wrote a master's
thesis on Jeopardy and why the clues are
in certain places they knew she was
going to be really really good and so I
don't think it was fixed that he was
going to lose but I do think they said
all right we're gonna put up our best
against him to see if he could break the
record well that makes more sense than
anything else I've heard I had heard too
that some of the Jeopardy writers like
weren't happy with the way James played
because he wouldn't go in the kids tack
yeah played against they say a lot of
people from now on are gonna play James
who of the daily doubles he only got one
I guess is on the phone guys the spider
in Richards brain so he went in through
your ear now he's in your head
I'm gonna lay my egg
[Laughter]